Donald Trump's ignoramus staffers really need
to stop saying the quiet part out loud for
their own benefit.
Donald Trump has this total buffoon of an
acting chief of staff.
Remember, there's no permanent chief of staff
right now.
The acting chief of staff is a Mick Mulvaney.
We're going to get into a lot more of this
wacky interview he gave yesterday to Chris
Wallace on Fox news Sunday.
Later on in the program, but I want to get
one clip in front of you today where Mick
Mulvaney has admitted that Donald Trump, despite
being president of the United States, which
is a full time job, by the way, Donald Trump
still considers himself to be in the hospitality
business as president of the United States,
which is effectively an admission that just
like anyone with a brain suspected, Trump
is still running his businesses.
Trump is still involved in his businesses
despite being president of the United States.
Mulvaney among other incredibly dumb things
that he said yesterday to Chris Wallace, which
I'll get to a little bit later, said Trump
is still in the business.
The context here is that Trump said he would
host the G seven summit at his own club, Doral.
Then they made the decision to cancel that
because it is after all, a completely unconstitutional
violation of the Amalio [inaudible] clause.
Here's Mick Mulvaney saying it himself.
He is back.
He's decided that he's not going to hold it.
A DRL, a P blames it on crop, the hostile
media and their democratic partners.
But again, he was getting hammered by Republicans.
So why did he cave?
Um, we talked about a great link last night.
Um, and it's not lost on me that if we've
made the decision on Thursday, we wouldn't
have had the press conference on Thursday
regarding, uh, regarding everything else,
but that's fine.
Um, but we didn't talk about it last night
and I honestly think what you saw on the tweet
was real.
The president isn't one for holding back.
He's his feelings in his emotions about something.
He was honestly surprised at the level of
pushback.
At the end of the day, you know, he still
considered himself to be in the hospitality
business and he saw an opportunity to take
the biggest leaders from around the world,
and he wanted to put on the absolute best,
uh, show the best visit that he possibly could.
And so then
Mulvaney filibusters a little bit, but Chris
Wallace makes the right decision and he goes
back to, hold on a second.
The president of the United States has another
vocation he considers himself too.
While president still be in the hospitality
industry.
I just have to pick up, you say he considers
himself in the hospitality business.
He's the president of the United States.
Yeah, but he's [inaudible].
That's his background.
It's like I used to be in the real estate
business.
I don't know what you used to do before you
were in in media, if anything, that's all
I've ever done, but he wanted to put on a
show.
The right follow up there would have been
when Mick Mulvaney says, well, yeah, I mean
I was in real estate before Chris Wallace
should had said, okay, but now you're the
chief of staff.
Another full time job of extraordinary importance
to the running of our government.
Do you still consider yourself today to be
in the real estate business?
Chris wall is not following up in that way
and we are going to have a lot more about
Mulvaney later on in the program.
I believe Mulvaney may be out door soon.
He's going out of his way now to say total
nonsense just to defend Donald Trump.
And the thing about that is that in the short
term Trump rewards you when you express this
unhinging and unflinching loyalty to Donald
Trump in the short term where you will go
on TV and say anything, no matter how ridiculous
to defend Donald Trump, Trump rewards you
in the immediate, but then other Republicans
start to cringe.
The crazy things that the staffer says become
a distraction.
They become the subject of news coverage on
corporate media, both left right and center.
And that's when then Donald Trump starts to
back away.
And next thing you know he says he has full
confidence in you in 48 hours later that you're
gone, you're, you end up actually being gone.
So this may be the beginning of the end for
Mick Mulvaney and after the break we are going
to get into his full interview with Chris
Wallace where Chris Wallace does a very good
job of pointing out that Mick Mulvaney is
now denying.
Having said things that are on camera, we
have recordings 2019 technology allows us
to go back to the tape so to speak, and look
at what it is that you said.
So we're going to get back to that.
As far as Trump is currently still in the
hospitality industry, the progression usually
is no, I never actually said that.
Then Chris Wallace shows you a clip of you
saying it.
Then it's, well, I said it, but I meant it
as a joke or it wasn't literal.
Then Trump's co Trump comes back and says,
wait, no, hold on.
I am still in the hospitality industry and
I'm the best at it.
At which point Mulvaney has to flip and say,
Oh no.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was serious when I said it and it's actually
fine for the president to both be president
of the United States and still be in the hospitality
industry.
Question to you is this is Mulvaney saying
Trump is still in the hospitality industry.
Do you think that this is stupidity or do
you think that they are deliberately trolling
at this point?
What do you believe is going on here?
Are they messing with people by saying absolute
and total nonsense like this or do you think
that they are actually this dumb to say the
quiet part out loud?
Leave a comment.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet
at D Pacman if you are watching or listening
to the program anywhere else and while you're
on Twitter, just a suggestion.
Follow the David Pakman show at [inaudible],
David Pakman show